hablamos ahora de salud en directo a
américa que nuestra periodista
especializada más romeros a la mar muy
buen día feliz lunes para usted vamos a
hablar entonces de los últimos avances
de la pandemia contra el commit 19 y
también de la reciente entrega por
supuesto del nobel de medicina
precisamente raúl vamos a empezar por
ahí por este premio que han recibido
david julius y are the mapa está putian
para detallar bien cuáles son estos
avances que han hecho en los receptores
de temperatura y de tacto estamos con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor muy buenos días un
lunes más cuéntenos en qué consiste en
esta investigación que han desarrollado
los premiados por el nobel
es un merecido reconocimiento para
entender una de las situaciones más
complejas que es como nosotros los
humanos nos comunicamos con el medio
ambiente la descripción de los
termorreceptores y mika nos receptores y
nos ha hecho entender como en nuestra
dinámica para entender de los principios
físicos en principios químicos y
desarrollar digamos todas las
estrategias para protegernos del calor
para controlar el dolor ha sido un
reconocimiento maravilloso para estos
doctores que dedicaron su vida a
entender la fisiología del dolor y la
temperatura en mis manos ahora doctor
los saludos felices de para usted y le
pregunto qué implicaciones tiene esto
para nuestra salud y en qué nos puede
ayudar
son inmensas desde el control del dolor
desde el manejo de los analgésicos el
control de la respiración todas las
implicaciones que tienen alrededor de
los seres humanos su comportamiento sus
alteraciones y entender esas
alteraciones para dar terapias a través
de los mexicanos y termorreceptores pues
abrieron un gran rumbo para la humanidad
por sí ya controlamos el dolor por los
hallazgos que ellos describieron
doctor y dejemos momento los nobel
gracias por toda esta información y
pasemos a la pandemia que no paramos de
hablar de ella pero siguiendo en esta
investigación como las investigaciones
nos ayudan a mejorar nuestra salud
precisamente dos grandes farmacéuticas
anunciaron avances muy significativos en
el desarrollo de una píldora antiviral
que serviría para tratar el cogito una
vez la persona está infectada cuéntenos
bien que que con en qué consiste un
tratamiento antiviral
esta es una noticia supremamente
importante para controlar una pandemia
necesitamos tres cosas 1 disciplina
social 2 la vacunación es decir la
profilaxis y 3 tratamientos efectivos lo
que nos anuncian ahora con estos
antivirales directos es la posibilidad
de tratamientos efectivos y esto sí
daría un cierre a ese rompecabezas para
poder superar la pandemia actúan
directamente en el virus para que no se
replique todos los medicamentos que
tenemos actualmente son para evitar la
inflamación y las consecuencias pero no
la causa y este medicamento directamente
afecta a la causa la reeducación viral y
por eso es importante este hallazgo
porque reduce la mortalidad y la
hospitalización de los pacientes con
colt doctor le pregunto entonces las
ventajas que presenta tener una pastilla
contra el coi 19
claro son tratamientos ambulatorios que
iniciando los síntomas se puede empezar
a tomar este medicamento
evita que el paciente vaya a un hospital
lo cual es impresionantemente importante
y además de eso de ser un tratamiento
oral oral y con bajos efectos adversos
pues eso hace que sea significativamente
importante y accesible para la comunidad
y para todos nosotros importante ahora
revisar los datos las publicaciones y
las aprobaciones para implementar esta
estrategia terapéutica lo más pronto
posible el doctor hay una propuesta de
facer y hay otra de merck que además
están en momentos de los estudios
distintos cuéntenos en qué consisten en
sus tratamientos y si hay diferencias
entre ellos
hay algunas diferencias en esencias son
antivirales directos es decir que
directamente evitar la replicación viral
algunos lo hacen como monoterapia en los
mexicanos de falset parece que es una
asociación de antivirales y lo que se
está desarrollando ahorita es en
voluntarios cómo se comporta y cuánto
disminuye el riesgo de hospitalización
msd ya nos dio el informe que reduce en
un 50% el riesgo de hospitalización y
muerte estamos pendientes de los datos
de facer pero son muy prometedoras
porque son estrategias para prevenir que
el virus se replique y realmente sería
el final de una pandemia junto con las
vacunas y la disciplina social doctor
pues muy buenas noticias entonces nos
llevamos de la crónica de hoy raúl
espero espero que estés contenta estoy
muy contento más gracias ahora vamos con
nuestro segundo invitado